- We've got Amy Schumer in the house!
- The college instinct in me is like--
- And the college instinct is right!
- This is exactly what
we wanted you to do!
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
- Amy Schumer didn't even
have to explain the game!
- Guys, I went to a state school.
- We are here on the Emmy's
red carpet finding out
the most important thing.
- And that is, who's the best at flip cup?
Let's find out.
You guys look like a
great team, obviously.
You probably can work together well.
Have you ever played flip cup before?
Where you try to flip the cup
over, so put it on the edge
there.
- Yeah?
- Actually, flip it back over.
- You hold the cup like
this, you flip it and it has
to land.
- I am a lesbian, if it's
a competition, I'm in!
- I haven't played this in years.
- Good luck.
- Damn.
- That counts, yeah?
- Yes!
- Aw, crap.
- Was that good?
- Slo-mo, I did it in
slo-mo, that was amazing.
- Let's give it a go!
- I never played before.
(all cheering)
- With the assist!
- Cheater, liar, cheater.
- No, I lose.
- Oh my God.
- Yes, queen, yes, queen!
- That was so sad.
- No, that's it.
- I like this game a lot more.
- A little aggressive, okay, alright.
- Sorry I'm so good at everything, guys.
- This is getting physical.
- Get it, I have to get it!
- You know the college I
visited, I went to Towson
University in Baltimore, I
went and visited and I won
a flip cup tournament and
that's why I went there, so.
- Scholarship?
- Scholarship, full ride.
- That's a crazy school.
- Don't remember a day of it.